Let's see if we can use our new system of equations to problem solve. Here's
our first problem. It would take 42 feet of fencing to enclose the rectangular
patio. If the area of the patio is 108 square feet, what are the dimensions of
the patio? So, here, this is my patio in black and then, this orange part is my
fencing. Now, this view isn't so helpful. We're going to take a bird's eye
view, and look down into our patio to figure this problem out. Essentially, our
pattern looks like this. It's a rectangle in shape, and it has a length and it
has a width. What we want to do is take our equations for perimeter and area.
And make them into two equations with a system of two variables. In other
words, we just want to have two equations with only l and w in them. Since we
know it would take 42 feet of fencing to enclose our rectangular patio We know
that the perimeter equals 42 feet. Notice that eh perimeter is even, so we can
divide each of these by two to get a new equation that is 21 equals l plus w.
We know the area of the patio is 108 square feet, so we can replace this area
with the value of 108. Now, notice that we have two equations with two
variables, l and w. This is a system of equations, and we've solved something
like this before. We're going to go ahead and solve this system using
substitution. First I'm going to subtract w from both sides of this equation to
get 21 minus w equals L. So, now I want you to use substitution to solve this
system of equations. We know the length equals 21w, so we can replace this
length with 21 minus w. I want you to make this substitution and then solve for
the width and the length. After you solve, the length should be the longer side
between the two. As a hint, when you substitute 21 minus w in for l, you should
wind up with something that's quadratic. Use what you know about factoring, and
try and find the length and the width. Good luck here.